[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: It's a playground
staple a stationary ride
on cartoon animal that
bounces up and down
and rocks back and
forth, courtesy
of a huge spring underneath
secured into the ground.
The bouncy coil
base is what gives
this type of
playground equipment
its name, a spring rider.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The spring rider is a
playground favorite.
To withstand years of
rambunctious riders,
it has to be solid and durable.
Yet, for a toddler to be
able to rock back and forth,
it can't be too heavy.
That's why this spring is made
of thick steel and the animal,
of lightweight aluminum.
That sand core is
comprised of halves,
each made with an
aluminum mold--
duck-shaped, in this case.
Workers fill it with
sand and adhesive mix
that sets into a solid block.
They insert several
steel support rods,
fill to the top, and
even out the surface,
then expose two
hooks they'll later
grab to extract the
core half, once the sand
hardens in about 20 minutes.
Meanwhile, other
workers use an aluminum
pattern to make each half
of the duck casting mold.
After applying a powder release
agent to prevent sticky,
they cover the pattern
with a sieved mixture
of sand and clay.
They mount a frame
around the pattern
to contain the sand as
they add more and more,
repeatedly packing
it down in all areas
with a pneumatic ramming tool.
Then they remove
the frame and cover
the sand with a wooden board.
This provides a hard
surface for the press,
which now applies the weight
of about four midsize SUVs.
Then they flip over the
mold and remove the pattern
which formed the mold cavity.
The sand is now so
firmly compacted
that it holds the shape.
One half of the sand
mold has channels,
through which the molten metal
will flow into the cavity.
Workers now position
several 1/4 inch thick foam
spacers in the cavity and place
1/2 of the core on top of them.
The spacers elevate the
core, creating a 1/4 inch
cavity between core and mold.
The other half of
the core goes on top.
After placing spacers on top
of that to create a 1/4 inch
gap on this side as well,
they carefully lowered
the other half of the sand.
Now they're ready
to cast the duck.
The melting point
of aluminum is just
over 1,090 degrees Fahrenheit.
However, they heat much
higher to 1,400 degrees
so it'll flow faster and
fill the entire cavity
before beginning to solidify.
They pour the metal
through holes on top.
It flows through the
runners into the mold
cavity, which is that
1/4 inch gap surrounding
the duck-shaped core.
About 20 minutes
later, the metal
has cooled and solidified.
They break the mold apart
on a vibrating sieve,
releasing the aluminum
duck and shaking
out the core sand through a
hole at the bottom of the duck.
After cutting off excess
aluminum that hardened
in the runners, they
grind down the seam,
which formed in between
the two halves of the mold.
Next, they weld on aluminum
handles for the child to grip
when riding.
These handles are cast in
sand molds just like the duck.
Workers grind down the
weld and any sharp edges,
making the entire
surface nice and smooth.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Next, a coat of polyester powder
in bright, rubber ducky yellow,
then a 20 minute trip through
an oven to bake the coating,
making it ultra durable.
Now delicately airbrushed
with the urethane
enamel paint, the details
that bring Mr. Duck to life--
his feet, wings, bill, and eyes.
The thick coil that
makes this a spring rider
is made of a flexible
type of steel.
They bolt a steel
spacer play to it
then hide the bolts
under an aluminum cover.
After attaching a
footrest-- steel again--
they bolt the duck to the plate.
All these parts, like the duck,
are painted with baked on,
polyester coating.
The spring bolts to a concrete
block buried under ground.
Ducky and friends are
designed to withstand even
the harshest winters, letting
children enjoy a little spring
all year-round.
[MUSIC PLAYING]